this is the most dangerous time in our
history you recently discovered the
existence of an international criminal
organization with ties to former Nazis
rumor has it
Liz built an atom bomb to infiltrate
this organization we have no choice but
to work together Napoleon solo Illya
Kuryakin
the CIA's most effective agent AGB the
youngest man to join in their best
within three years obviously I was
pleased about your criminal background I
do wonder it was your father's shame
that gave you such drive up your balls
or at the end of a very long or was it
your mother's reputation I understand
that she was extremely popular amongst
your father's a friend
don't kill your partner on your first
day America teaming up with Russia what
does that mean so sorry I can't stay to
finish it with myself since some are
friendly things to get a little messy
see you tomorrow
I told you we're teaming up with the
Russians I work better blow you told me
this is gonna be a simple extraction you
work a bit throwing suit doesn't get any
more Russian than the red paralyzer
growers fines although you water
investigates Victoria Evans together it
would send an army to stop us we must
give them the crew very well I hope you
have a new code my code name uncle
I'll turn it on now
[Music]
[Music]